jessica dallow asks what's new on the
subject of high temperature or even room
temperature superconductors are we
getting any closer to grasping how it
works and will this knowledge in
conjunction with 3d printing create a
new industrial age
sounds like he's making a prediction of
his own doesn't it he's like am i right
what do you think he's a sage yeah we'll
see
maybe she's a sage 3d printing is
fabulous and uh
what's this what's the state of uh
superconductors and i don't know that
though we have superconductors that work
at
sort of liquid helium temperatures
everybody wants it's kind of cold though
yeah yeah four to four kelvin yeah yeah
four kelvin sounds cold it is cool even
colder than like canada yeah so it's
like super canada yeah
uh but wouldn't it be good if they work
with liquid nitrogen wouldn't they good
if they worked with
with frozen water yes but it's a long
way off as far as i know but that
doesn't mean it can't be done what i
would do where i king of the food is
is a vest again in these nanotubes in
the
getting carbon atoms to arrange
themselves in these extraordinary tubes
where they have very very low electrical
resistance all right
let's do it the 3d printing thing is
yeah it's supposed to be pretty amazing
carbon tubes
oh could we ever do that is that a thing
in the future seems very reasonable to
me but right not a carbon tube printer
but it's quite have you guys ever 3d
printed i've never done that they
haven't been and you know they're
affordable now sort of you can get them
at staples really yeah yeah wait how is
that in it how much are like of meaning
a few thousand dollars yeah or less than
two thousand dollars oh wow and then you
can make your own salt shakers i can't
wait to go home and make it i think
you're good and plastic swords too bad
we can't people can't see this for this
radio but yeah eugene's eyes was just
lit yeah yeah i was like he's ready to
get out of here and go buy a 3d printer
yeah but you know they they use them we
have them in the labs in the shops at
columbia for example and here and the
students learn how to use them and they
do incredible things with them the next
generation of kids will be like why
aren't you 3d printing that exactly why
are you going to a store to buy
something like that right yes so it's
additive machining if you've not thought
about it
generally when you shape something you
remove material
generally
but this is a process by which you add
materials
that's right it's quite a different idea
and you can make shapes that are
literally
were literally impossible to make wow
heretofore it's quite a time to be alive
it's exciting
you